although she's digitally rendered to
look alien Proxima midnight spice and
facial structure are sure to make you
ask yourself where do I know her from
Carrie Koons convincingly intimidating
motion capture performance in infinity
war is yet another impressive addition
to her acting resume talk about a
successful debut for her very first
feature film appearance Koons starred
alongside Ben Affleck and gone girl the
adaptation of Gillian Flynn's twisted
novel of the same name kun starred as
Margo done twin sister of Affleck's
leading man Nick Dunne she got the part
by sending in on audition tape and she
must have really knocked it out of the
park in order to get cast the
old-fashioned way kun really showcased
the full range of her acting chops and
it definitely had an effect on the film
success gone girl was a massive
box-office hit
bringing in nearly 370 million dollars
worldwide if the first movie you ever
acting goes on to become one of the top
20 highest-grossing films of the year
you must be doing something right HBO's
psychological mystery drama the
leftovers focused on the lives of
several people who remained on earth
after 2% of the entire global population
vanished and a rapture like event the
series ran for three seasons and 28
episodes from 2014 to 2017 kun portrayed
nora durst a grieving widow who lost
both her husband and her children in the
event she still views her work on the
show with great regard in an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter she raved
about how it affected her career
declaring I rarely get recognized and
whenever I do it has to do with the
leftovers because it came into someone's
life at a particularly important time
for them if they were dealing with grief
or loss or whatever tragedy and they
just caught it in the spring of 2017
Koons acting career really caught fire
while simultaneously shooting the
leftovers she also joined the cast of
FX's smash hit series Fargo for its
third season a black comedy wrapped up
in a crime anthology the show was based
on the Coen brothers 1996 film of the
same name kuhn starred as gloria burgled
the recently divorced chief of police
and snowy Eden Valley Minnesota those
are facts and you at the heart of the
morass what else am I supposed to see
despite starring alongside such a list
actors as you and McGregor and Mary
Elizabeth Winstead [ __ ] commanded
viewers attention even earning an Emmy
nomination for lead actress and a
limited series or TV movie in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly she
opened up a bit about the spring of
Carrie [ __ ] saying oh gosh this year
this extraordinary year it's funny I
feel like I'm still processing this year
that I've had I feel I've been working
non-stop for years now and I haven't had
time to take a breath it's generally
considered a great honor to work on a
Steven Spielberg film and Carrie [ __ ] is
one of the lucky talents who can flaunt
that achievement on our IMDB page in the
post she portrayed journalist Meg
Greenfield a proud member of the
Washington Post team responsible for
publishing the Pentagon Papers in 1971
the film which also starred Tom Hanks
and Meryl Streep brought in nearly 180
million dollars at the worldwide box
office and nabbed two Oscar nominations
although her role was fairly minor
Koontz time on the set with an acclaimed
director and two of the biggest names in
Hollywood history is not an experience
she will soon forget
she told parade the thing that I loved
about working with Meryl Tom and Stephen
is that they also clearly still love
what they're doing they've been making
films for decades and it's still magical
for them still moving for them and
important Steve McQueen's widows
featured an all-star cast led by Viola
Davis Michelle Rodriguez Elizabeth to
Vicki and Liam Neeson and although her
role was small you can't forget to
include Carrie [ __ ] on that list the
2018 film follows four women forced to
embark on a heist after their gangster
husbands are killed Kuhn plays Amanda
one of the widows who decides not to
partake in the plan although it garnered
a decent amount of buzz prior to its
release it ultimately didn't fare too
well at the box office only earning 76
million dollars worldwide in an
interview with observer Kuhn dished
about her favorite parts of working on
widows which was shot in her hometown of
Chicago she appreciated McQueen bringing
his unique point of view to a genre film
working alongside greats such as Davis
and Neeson and getting to sleep in her
own bed for a change in the acting world
you can't put a price tag on working
close to home in the first season of
USA's dark mystery thriller the
Jessica Biel shined as a woman coming to
grips with the demons of her past for
season 2 the showrunners needed to find
a new leading lady to fill Beals shoes
although she wasn't their first choice
the role of commune leader Veera Walker
eventually went to [ __ ] she sneaks into
your room at night and sits on your
chest
have you ever been visited by her the
really interesting part of this story is
that [ __ ] hadn't even intended to be on
the show at all it was actually her
husband Hewlett surprise winning
playwright Tracy Letts
who received the casting call for the
role of Jack Novak
since kun had just delivered their first
child she was looking forward to taking
some time off from acting but when the
role of Bureau reopened they offered it
to kun and the rest is history check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorites topper coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]